this video is brought to you by
newsreels the smartest news app on the
market but more about that a little
later on
[Music]
for now pay attention to this statement
declaration of intent
china our great neighbor will help
afghanistan burj bees taliban
china our great neighboring country can
play a constructive and positive role in
the reconstruction of afghanistan and
also in the economic development and
prosperity of the afghan people sahel
shaheen spokesman for the taliban in the
daha office on the 7th of october 2001
the united states launched operation
enduring freedom and began the invasion
of afghanistan it started a war that did
not end until the 31st of august 2021
almost 20 years later with the taliban
ultimately regaining power
[Applause]
despite almost two decades of
controlling the country and having
invested billions of dollars the united
states was unable to establish an
autonomous effective and lasting afghan
state this is something we all saw when
the country fell to the taliban after
the withdrawal of u.s troops suddenly
every news agency in the world is
covering this story and it can seem like
each one has a different interpretation
of what is happening now which only
seems to fuel the polarizing effect of
us government decisions and that's where
today's sponsor comes in
newsreels is the smartest news app on
the market because it makes it easy to
access news from different sources
something that we try to do regularly in
our research to get a feel for the
bigger picture in the topics we cover
you can quickly get your dose of daily
news by simply scrolling through the
reels page like you would on tick tock
or instagram reading the news in bullet
points and watching news reels will help
keep you updated on things that matter i
personally love it because it just saves
me so much time newsreels allows you to
absorb a lot of information quickly so
you can always be up to date they chop
the clutter to save you time okay back
to our coverage of afghanistan in the
two previous videos here on
visualpolitik which i'll link for you in
the description we told you the key
factors that explain the rapid collapse
of the afghan army and the seizure of
power by the taliban but there were
still some crucial questions left
unanswered what went wrong despite
having 20 years why was the united
states unable to build a strong state an
effective political apparatus and what
does the future now hold for the country
who do the taliban trust and perhaps the
most important question of all for many
what exactly is going on with china what
role will it play in the construction of
this new afghanistan listen up
a state of cardboard and stone
[Music]
for years the united states tried to
implement and develop a democratic state
model in afghanistan that would allow
the country to modernize a state with
its own constitution legislative bodies
modern armed forces independent courts
and so on and so forth and the truth is
that during the two decades of u.s
control many advances were made and in
general the standard of living of the
afghans improved considerably for
example healthcare and education were
extended throughout the country eight
million more children are in school
today than in 2001. the proportion of
young people enrolled in secondary
education rose from 12 to more than 55
percent and afghanistan had the most
rapid reduction in child mortality of
all low-income countries according to
the world bank and of course the
situation of women in society has
substantially improved the problem is
that basically everything depended on
the huge checkbook of the u.s taxpayer
who was basically paying for the whole
party and in fact things started to go
alright in 2014 as north american funds
began to dry up
when it came down to it afghans did not
feel represented by the state economic
development was scarce and the
credibility of institutions was
conspicuous by its absence to make
matters worse since 2015 the economy has
practically stalled but in many ways we
already knew this if one thing has
become clear it is that the afghan state
and the political economic model
promoted by the united states was
anything but functional the question is
why why on earth was the world's great
power incapable of putting in place a
political model that worked well
basically we can identify three key
factors three big mistakes made by the
united states of america in its afghan
incursion the first of these has to do
with the state model a suffocating
centralism that had nothing to do with
the reality of the country
[Music]
afghanistan is a country fragmented by
tribes ethnicities and disparate local
communities despite this the united
states developed one of the most
centralized state models in the world
all power and decision making was
concentrated in the central government
in kabul and not surprisingly when the
country is so diverse ankle board's
control over the territory as a whole
has been historically shallow then
problems arise this almost absolute
centralism meant that local communities
and elites did not feel involved in
decision-making and that the central
state distributed resources and made
decisions without a good understanding
of the various local realities or needs
accountability was also made more
difficult since no one was responsible
and there were no control mechanisms no
one was willing to get involved in
denouncing the work of others from
contractors to doctors who never visited
the hospitals therefore the only
incentive for the elites and government
officials was to line their pockets and
depending on the case blame the capital
or local officials
[Music]
the fact is that this national model
meant that the different communities did
not develop ties or links with the
government of the republic an entity
that was alien to them and which to top
it all off had been set up by a foreign
power and not only that this state
structure along with the huge amounts of
money that came with the international
troops provoked the second huge mistake
the development of a rentia and terribly
corrupt model
[Music]
that is professionals companies even the
military and civil servants all parties
specialized in chasing uncle sam's
dollars it was something akin to the
well-known curse of natural resources
only in this case it was the curse of
international aid let me explain let's
say that the best way to make money was
not to create real businesses and
competitive companies but to look for
ways to tap into and get as much of the
international money as possible and that
thinking that not only slowed
development but also fueled for rampant
corruption you start looking for a
couple of uncle sam's dollars and end up
demanding bribes from drivers to use a
road according to estimates by the
united nations and some foundations
afghans paid bribes to public officials
including the police themselves totaling
more than 2.5 billion every year and of
course this explains why in 2020
two-thirds of afghans considered
corruption to be on the rise and one of
the most serious problems in the country
indeed for many years corruption was
perceived by afghans as a bigger problem
than the lack of security itself
people consistently told me the taliban
regime was authoritarian in ways that
they detested but that it was not
corrupt sarah chase former adviser to
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff of the us military evidently this
situation had two direct consequences on
the one hand the state was not effective
in fulfilling its tasks and on the other
afghans did not trust it and as a result
we're not willing to risk their lives
defending it but wait a minute because
we're not done yet
together with the centralism imposed by
the united states and the permissiveness
of the rentier corrupt states of karzai
ghani and company we can find a third
glaring error lack of non-military
vision this is something we have already
commented on in a past video and also in
our exclusive newsletter for all of you
who support us on patreon according to
estimates by the watson institute at
brown university the united states has
spent about 2.3 trillion dollars to date
in the afghan campaign that's trillions
with a capital t well do you know what
percentage of this huge amount of money
has been allocated to policies and plans
to boost development that is to things
like infrastructure agricultural
equipment financing for entrepreneurs
digital connectivity or education among
many other possibilities well hold on to
your chair because you're gonna need it
less than one percent of total spending
that's less than 23 billion dollars and
maybe not even that because out of that
budget many programs that had nothing to
do with development were paid for how do
you hope to support a country's
development if you spend less than one
percent of your resources on the economy
business and infrastructure and
concentrate all of your spending on
military operations troop deployments
and counter narcotics you can't and
that's exactly what happened more than
two trillion dollars later the afghan
government has dissolved like a sugar
cube and the country remains one of the
poorest in the world and life expectancy
is a mere 63 years a complete disaster
but wait a minute because there is
something in this whole story that
explains this debacle that is now
unfolding look at this graph
what you see represents with all
possible nuances the evolution of the
gdp per capita in purchasing power
parity in afghanistan at least that of
legal activities well as you can see
around 2014 the growth disappeared and
exactly the same thing happened with per
capita imports which began to fall and
take note because in a country that
produces limited food and basic goods
and has to buy them abroad this means
worse living conditions and much more
social discontent
and you know what this evolution was not
accidental between 2011 and 2015 u.s
spending in afghanistan fell by more
than 50 percent and of course with an
inoperative economy plagued by
corruption and focused on squeezing
international aid well when the economy
stopped growing and aid began to shrink
then everything began to take a nosedive
[Music]
and you see it is something relatively
well documented for example according to
some studies by the university of oslo
and also by the london school of
economics low economic growth not the
level of income but low economic growth
the lack of prosperity favors
revolutionary or insurgent processes
even more so in muslim countries that
are not entirely free or poor
democracies so yes they landed that
target right in the middle of the
bullseye in other words when prosperity
began to dwindle in 2014 and per capita
economic growth even entered negative
territory it created the perfect
opportunity for the taliban to gain
followers and social support across the
country and set against a backdrop of
rampant corruption and the lack of a
sense of representation from the central
government the stage was soon set for
the currents to buckle and in this case
i think the facts speak for themselves
but at this point i think it's time to
look ahead what does the future look
like for afghanistan what challenges do
the taliban face and the most important
question of all will this country become
a kind of chinese colony well listen up
[Music]
the taliban economy
the taliban have won but now they face
the hardest challenge of all afghanistan
has been in crisis for several years now
more than three out of four afghans are
mired in poverty and the impact of the
coronavirus and a severe drought
prompted the un world food programme to
warn that more than 14 million afghans
were facing food insecurity even before
the fall of the u.s backed government
and you know what this is a crisis that
the taliban now have to deal with at the
same time the country is losing the
international donations that previously
financed more than 70 of public spending
and that's not to mention the huge
exodus of human capital that is being
experienced or the impact that their
unhinged policies is having do you want
an example then take a look
[Music]
in recent years the media industry has
been one of the most thriving according
to the figures of the former pre-taliban
governments we are talking about almost
250 television stations more than 400
radio stations and more than 1 500 print
media outlets now everything is changing
although the taliban have promised
freedom to of the press as long as it
complies with islamic law journalists
are being persecuted television
reporters have been flogged in public
and the work of women in the media has
begun to be restricted of course no one
is throwing any money at the survival of
one of the country's most thriving
industries
don't even think that this is an
isolated case so things are obviously
not looking good at all
[Music]
to give you an idea according to imf
data the country needs more than 5
billion of external financing every year
to keep things from collapsing and the
question now is who on earth is going to
lend that money to a country led by a
religious extremist group in the same
vein many experts point out that
afghanistan faces a high risk of
hyperinflation a sharp drop in per
capita income and serious problems in
financing even the most basic public
services all this is something that
could fuel opposition movements to the
taliban themselves or even feed more
radical organizations such as isis k the
sweet and sour given such a context the
question we can now ask ourselves is
what do the taliban depend on well it
seems mining has a lot to answer for
here
[Music]
you see ending the era of oil gas and
coal requires an energy transition that
depends on some key minerals such as
copper lithium or rare earths among
others minerals that afghanistan could
have in large quantities for example in
may 2021 the international energy agency
published a forecast that lithium demand
could multiply by as much as 40 times in
the next 20 to 30 years and guess what a
pentagon report cited in the new york
times suggested that afghanistan thanks
to its huge reserves of this mineral
could become a kind of saudi arabia of
lithium what's more a report by the
afghan government itself pointed out
that the country's copper reserves could
approach 60 million tons which would put
the country in the top five of copper
reserves worldwide
[Music]
but let's put the brakes on for a second
it is one thing to have mineral reserves
and quite another to be able to exploit
them
realized mining requires more than
geological abundance it also requires
security infrastructure energy resources
water resources and a skilled workforce
rod shoenova head of the uf strategic
risk council's ecological security
program
in mining it can take 10 or 20 years
from the discovery of a deposit to its
exploitation no company will want to
invest if there is no stable political
and legal framework gion pitron author
of the book the rare metals war at the
end of the day afghanistan has nowhere
near the infrastructure necessary for
large-scale mining at best it will take
many years to set up and would require a
huge investment exactly the same thing
happens with a pipeline project like the
tapi that we have already covered in our
first video of this trilogy on
afghanistan what is needed is stability
legal certainty knowledge and lots and
lots of money and it is right here
precisely here that all eyes are on
china listen up
china's latest colony
do you remember this new story
china our great neighbor will help
afghanistan forge peace taliban it seems
clear to the taliban china has the
capital the technology and the appetite
for minerals and business that their
theocratic emirate needs in order to get
ahead and in a way it is not unusual
china has been the largest foreign
investor in afghanistan since 2010 and
in 2007 the china metallurgical group
corporation took a 3 billion lease on a
copper mine in mez and yak china has
been the largest foreign investor in
afghanistan since 2010 and in 2007 the
china metallurgical group corporation
took a 3 billion lease on a copper mine
in mez inac a region 26 miles or 40
kilometers south of kabul the largest
foreign investment in the country's
history for its part the china national
petroleum corporation won a tender in
2011 to drill three oil fields in the
amudaria river basin for 25 years
in other words chinese interest in
afghan resources exist and has a long
history now with the withdrawal of the
united states the path seems clear for
beijing to become the most influential
player in the country
[Music]
think about it for a moment the taliban
need money investment and perhaps even
political protection in response china
has money experience in investing in
high-risk countries a veto in the united
nations security council and is dead set
on getting its hands on the raw
materials it needs in the technological
war with the united states besides
democracy or human rights well let's
just say that those things are not too
high on their agenda in other words they
look like two partners doomed to come
together in fact even before the
takeover of kabul taliban had already
promised to protect chinese investments
in afghanistan however not everything is
as straightforward as it seems
do you think afghanistan will develop
peacefully and steadily from now on do
you think afghanistan has unlimited
business opportunities right away do you
think afghanistan is extremely important
for the new silk road do you think wake
up metinya researcher at the ministry of
commerce of the people's republic of
china taking advantage of resources in
afghanistan involves huge investments
and a very long-term vision and not only
that it also requires stability in the
country once and for all a country that
let's not forget has been at war for 40
years the chinese government is aware
that it now has the upper hand the
departure of the united states from
afghanistan makes china an indispensable
player for the country especially of
course for the taliban however
on the other hand many chinese analysts
are also warning against getting too
deep into the hornets nest from which no
one will emerge unscathed chinese
companies that have invested in
afghanistan have seen their projects
languish for years due to corruption and
a lack of both security and basic
infrastructure there is also the example
of india which after having invested
more than three billion dollars in the
country is now out of the game thanks to
the arrival of the taliban afghanistan
is like that unpredictable and
uncontrollable
and then let's not forget this country
afghanistan is going to be a hotspot for
jihadist groups groups like the isis k
or east turkestan islamic movement a
group of uyghur militants who dream of
creating an islamic caliphate in an area
that would include chinese territory
will the taliban be able to stop these
jihadist groups it is not clear that
they will be able to or that they would
even want to anyway as you can see the
stage appears to be set for afghanistan
to become a kind of lacky country of the
asian giant but be careful because
nothing is set in stone at the moment
the future of afghanistan looks bleak
very bleak but having come this far it's
your turn do you think china will
eventually take control of afghanistan
leave your comments below and if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to hit the like button all the
best and see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you